I set the record for the lowest limbo of
8.5 inches in 2010 very proud of that my
name is shima Campbell and I am a
world-class level dancer
[Music]
I'm originally from Trinidad and Tobago
which is also where limbo dance
originated it was a dance at wakes to
symbolize entering from one life to
another now today is literally
everywhere I got into the art of limbo
at the age of 14 my grandmother was a
limbo dance there my mother was a loon
look in there and it's only right that I
little dancer
I had to carry on that legacy not only
for my family but also for my culture as
well physically I am very flexible I do
my daily stretches I can't really feel
normal stretches so I have to like
create my own so where I would really
feel the stretching my legs I get a
little crazy sometimes for sure in order
to make it under 8.5 inches I have to
hold my breath in order to contort my
body to make it under the bar at the
same time I have to think about my arms
I have to think about my positioning I
move side to side just to show that I'm
still suspended I start to move actually
physically under the bar and that's
pretty much when I made wood so let the
air out and that's when I will get up
it's very very very hard to do the pain
that I feel during practicing and
pushing myself that comes with it but
that's one of the things that really
drew me to limbo
it was something that I couldn't do
easily I love the challenge me making it
under this bar perfectly every time
it means the absolute world
I pretty much limbo any and everywhere
I've been on America's Got Talent twice
I've been on The Ellen DeGeneres Show
I've been on The Late Late Show with
James Corden when I see people's
reactions and how appreciative they are
of my ability to do this is just amazing
I absolutely love them both I love
everything about it
people think that Limbaugh was just for
fun for Trinidadians like myself is
really a big part of our culture I feel
like that's where my job comes in to
really show you this is more than just a
fun little activity
[Music]
you get skinny and then you want to
cover it up I just wore clothing baggy
clothes things that hid my body I would
have little games in my head that I
would play like let's see how long I can
go without eating I would definitely
still be starving myself if I had not
found circus arts I'm Kayla dykes and
I'm a professional aerialist
and a survivor of anorexia I did
gymnastics and developed anorexia and my
pains into my 20s at my lowest point I
was 90 pounds and that's when I
discovered circus arts it changed my
life
because I knew that if I wanted to do it
I needed to grow stronger and grow from
it
it took me eight years to get from there
to here anorexia never really goes away
you just learn how to shut it out
when I look in the mirror now I don't
see the muscle mass I feel small
almost immediately I'm thinking you know
that's not true you can climb 200 feet
straight up I had no idea from my first
day that this would end up being my
profession back then you know I would
cook a pot of noodles and I would have
to get my then-husband to strain the
noodles for me because I didn't have the
strength to lift the pot of water
noodles and pour it out and I remember
asking like what is wrong with me and
one of my trainers looked at me and she
said you need to eat I had fallen in
love with Arielle so much so that I was
willing to put food in my mouth and grow
some muscle so I can get up in the air
and keep up with all my classmates
[Music]
if I could say anything to my inner XXL
it would be that you could be so much
nicer to your body at the time I thought
I was taking care of it
I wasn't and I didn't know any better
I'm capable of so much more
[Music]
it's me walking upside down on all fours
is as easy as walking on two feet it's
not scary or frightening to me in the
least
I've always been flexible but not just a
little bit flexible I'm I'm really
flexible little did I know that
disability was in fact the tower that
had changed my life completely I'm Troy
James and I'm a creature actor I play
creatures on TV and movies that move in
ways that make the audience squirt my
talent is the bat all of my joints my
legs my arms my shoulders my fingers
they just bend over I want them to so if
you need an alien demon or a nonhuman
creature that doesn't move in ways that
normal human people do that's when you
call me it looks like what I do is
extremely painful really it doesn't hurt
at all I don't know why I am as flexible
as I am
it's just something I was born with I'm
the only one of my family who can bed
dis arms and legs the way I do I didn't
think it was that strange until other
kids told me it was but they weren't
very nice about it and I remember being
very embarrassed and I hid it away
because what makes you different when
you're growing up isn't something to be
proud of I hid it for a long time but
that all changed when I caught a job as
an amusement park ride operator there's
a hot day the ride was down for some
reason or another the guests were
getting kind of ornery and I thought why
don't I show them what I could do and I
went up and down the line making really
cool shapes with my body and it was a
hit and that was the first time I gotten
that sort of positive reaction from
other people showcasing my talent I
never thought my ability was anything
more than a really cool party trick my
friend put his camera up to me and said
show me something cool then he posted it
on the Internet
and all of a sudden my phone started
ringing I started getting calls to be
cast in TV shows and I didn't look back
if you had told me a year ago I was
going to be an actor I would have
laughed at you but after some of my
performances people have told me that
it's not just the way I'm with my body
that's effective it's the acting behind
it I bring a reaction of the audience I
can throw them so to speak coming from a
place where you were ostracized as I was
as a child I can bring that out as a
creature
it's interesting that something that I
hid for so long is now taking me places
that I never imagined they would go I
believe everyone has a superpower and
you may not know it's a superpower but
if it's something that you're passionate
about makes it happy I think sharing it
with the world may not be such a bad
idea after all
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there's a certain feeling of adrenaline
once you get up there in the air it's a
feeling unlike any other
you feel power you feel like you're in
control you feel special
that's what makes chappies beautiful
that's what makes the circus beautiful
[Music]
my name is Kristen Finlay and I'm a
trapeze artist
15 years ago I was working for brewery
in Los Angeles I had a great life making
great money that had you know my Lexus
and I had a house I was only you know 24
years old a friend of mine told me that
she was flying trapeze and I said what
are you doing I want to come watch I
ended up taking a class and I was hooked
it was addictive ride away and I'd quit
my life in LA and I joined the circus
I went from good paid to zero pay just
had to give everything up pretty much
overnight and here we are 15 years later
I never looked back and I've been on the
road ever since to run away and join the
circus it takes commitment you have to
be ready for anything you have to kind
of live on your toes because you never
know what's gonna happen your own
personal space your RV or whatever
that's your home and that's what has to
be stable inside whenever you're flying
trapeze you have to focus on what you're
doing and the moment you doubt yourself
in the middle of a trick most likely
you're going to mess up you're not going
to make it
the fact that I was able to do it made
it more appealing to me and I'm doing
these tricks and they're harder and
they're harder and this is awesome
whatever you want to do in your wildest
dreams do it
anything's possible there's not too many
african-american female circus
performers but I was still able to do it
your life is what you make of it and I
wouldn't change my life for the world I
really wouldn't